we are following breaking news from
Crimea where Russian officials say an
apparent bomb explosion killed at least
13 people this morning officials say the
possible terror attack happened in the
cafeteria of a vocational College in
Kerch in ancient city in eastern Crimea
most of the victims reportedly our
students Roxana Saberi is following this
story from London and brings us the
latest Roxana good morning what can you
tell us
well good morning as you said the blast
at the college killed at least 13 people
and wounded at least 50 others
investigators say the bomb was packed
with metal objects the blast cut through
a packed cafeteria full of teenage
students unconfirmed reports say that
gunmen also entered the college and
started shooting both pupils and staff
are believed to be among the dead
according to Russia's Investigative
Committee the committee has opened a
criminal case and are calling this a
terrorist attack local media are
reporting that other schools and
kindergartens in the area are now being
evacuated Nora